dans le cadre du quatrième plan de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
un colloque a été organisé au moca à
montgailhard la violence ne cesse
d'augmenter les chiffres sont alarmants
avec cinq plaintes enregistrées par jour
à la réunion alors les violences
conjugales à la réunion sont toujours
prégnante et graves par leur fréquence
et leur intensité
nous savons que
7 cinq plaintes sont déposées chaque
jour dans ce cadre les chiffres que nous
pouvons dire sur les violences
conjugales sont de toute façon peu trop
important nous serons en disant nous
avons enterré 56 femmes suite à des
violences dans la sphère privée en lien
avec des rapports conjugaux
et souvent le fait aggravant c'est aussi
l'alcool donc qui montrent en fait la
gravité de ses actes à la règle
l'enjeu de ce colloque promouvoir le
dépistage et la prise en charge des
victimes mais également d'orienter les
professionnels de santé au dépistage
systématique des situations de violence
aujourd'hui on est réunie sur le thème
de la santé donc des femmes exposées aux
violences
un thème qui jusqu'à présent n'a pas été
suffisamment travaillé alors qu'en
réalité les acteurs de santé ont un rôle
déterminant à ce niveau là autant pour
les femmes que pour les enfants qui sont
victimes et ils interviennent de
nombreuses fois ils sont souvent le
premier recours
ils sont également ceux qui accueillent
au niveau des urgences les situations
les plus graves et donc nous avons à
sensibiliser les acteurs de santé
nous avons à valoriser tout ce que ces
acteurs mettent en place et nous avons à
nous insérer également dans ce travail
de prise en charge sanitaire des
violences faites aux femmes la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
est une priorité pour le conseil
départemental
depuis plusieurs années la collectivité
a fait de cette cause
un axe majeur en mettant en place des
dispositifs pour lutter contre ces
violences mais aussi en cofinançant
diverses associations
alors la collectivité s'est fortement
engagée dans ce dispositif
depuis maintenant plus de dix ans
puisque la présidente du conseil
départemental en a fait un axe majeur de
son intervention depuis 2004 donc en
complémentarité des interventions qu'on
peut faire dans le cofinancement des
associations la présidente du
département était à l'origine en 2005 de
la mise en place du 115 qui est un
dispositif géré par l'état qu'elle a
transféré aux départements et qu'elle
agirait pendant une dizaine d'années
avec des cofinancements importante pour
permettre l'accompagnement et la prise
en charge des femmes la présidente a
également initié deux dispositifs
hébergement de ces femmes dans les
nuitées d'hôtel mais également un
accompagnement dans les taxiteurs pour
garantir une mise à l'abri
le conseil départemental se positionne
comme un partenaire de longue date dans
la mise en oeuvre d'actions de
prévention et de prise en charge dans la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes